I'm Laura Ingram this is Ingram angle
from Washington tonight thank you for
joining us
whatever happened to Hope and change
that's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now in 2008 long ago the Democrats
nominated a young optimistic
transformational figure now you might
not have liked his ideas I mean I didn't
but there's no denying that he excited
Democrats and even independents
the road ahead will be long
our climb will be steep
we may not get there in one year or even
in one term
but America I have never been more
hopeful than I am tonight that we will
get there
well 15 years later his party has gone
from Hope to nope as in nope they don't
want Biden the deterioration of our
economy well we've talked about this ad
nauseam it's obvious
but so is his own physical deterioration
now let's compare Biden from 15 years
ago to now
these are extraordinary times this is an
extraordinary election the American
people are ready I am ready Barack is
ready this is his time this is our time
this is America's time in and out of
Iraq and Iran Iraq and Iran but Iraq not
Iran it's really very very dull when
after all these years in public life
you're known for two things Ray-Ban
sunglasses and chocolate chip ice cream
wow no wonder 51 of his own voters do
not want him to run again according to
that new NBC survey that just came out
nearly three quarters of all surveyed
want Biden to step aside totally now his
approval is down to 36 percent among
young people Obama never fell below 41
with that same group
and of course you know 36 percent yes
young people aren't stupid they want a
future and they know they're not going
to get there with this guy in charge
now at this point Democrats are dividing
their time between trying to convince
Americans to get accustomed to a lower
standard of living and trying to mollify
progressives with a radical social
agenda
now the Democrats sold their soul to the
progressives and in the process have
alienated working-class voters and
independents
in 2020 were voters really clamoring for
the active promotion of transgenderism
and schools and women's sports
well you'd think so by the way the White
House has prioritized it
with regard to the lgbtq community which
right now is under attack let's let's be
honest they're under attack in this
country the Administration has uh is
going to do everything that they can to
protect lgbtqi plus people who are under
attack
and were the Biden voters in
Pennsylvania and in Georgia were they
really hoping for Endless racial
recriminations across every segment of
society of course not we know that
were Americans who voted Democrat in
2020 hoping that we'd spend hundreds of
billions of dollars in Ukraine
freedom is priceless
it's worth fighting for as long as it
takes America would will stand with
Ukraine for as long as it takes we are
committed to continuing to hold Russia
accountable and supporting Ukraine as
long as it takes we're going to be with
you Mr President for as long as it takes
and by voting for Biden did Democrats
hope that their wages and their buying
power would decline or that energy
prices would Skyrocket
we have also made historic investments
in clean energy in ways that are going
to make the middle class stronger more
vibrant and bigger than it was when
President Biden took office
to make things go back to normal
instead the opposite happened they got a
new normal that made them poorer and
that turned their Democratic party into
this wild hybrid of Liz Cheney and AOC
now if this was a political experiment
it would be called the gain of
dysfunction
well it turns out the squad and the rest
of the progressives on Capitol Hill
they're cheap dates
all Biden needed to do for them was to
throw them some money for climate
Justice and do some pro-trans executive
orders an AOC and Company were willing
to give in to the establishment on all
the big stuff
so much for the squads anti-war anti-big
Tech and anti-surveillance idealism
that's out the window
so instead of standing up to the big
donors in their own party they stood for
photo shoots with Vanity Fair
now how is it Progressive to suck up to
China because that's what progressives
and the party there are busy doing
morning noon and night
we do not seek to decouple our economy
from China's we seek a healthy economic
relationship with China a growing China
that plays by International rules is
good for the United States and the world
the growing China is good for the world
well that's the uyghurs
so despite everything that China is
doing for the whole world to see to
intimidate and terrorize and jail anyone
who questions them
progressives sit by mute trying to
pretend that Christian conservatives and
Trump supporters DeSantis supporters
that they're the ones endangering
democracy
do these people even read are they aware
of what China is threatening in Taiwan
or I don't know they only pay attention
to what their admirers are posting on
Tick Tock where's the money
where's the cash where's the check
Don't Be Afraid please don't be afraid
we need to do this we need to get the
money where's the money
this party has gone insane now Democrats
used to Pride themselves on being the
working class party but somewhere along
the way they decided to sell out to Wall
Street and give the shaft to Main Street
these Bush style Democrats became the
forever war party
and they bought off the progressive
Silence by promising to also go to war
with conservatives at home
remember how they laughed at Mitt Romney
in 2012 when he warned about Russia's
re-emergence
and now they have us bogged down in a
proxy war against Russia that Ukraine is
not winning
their people used to protest in cities
like Seattle Against the World Trade
Organization and now they bowed down to
the WTO and support all sorts of obscene
lopsided trade deals now this has given
a huge advantage to foreign countries
and led to the Outsourcing of millions
of American jobs
and of course Like A working class party
can't also be an open borders party
which is precisely what the Democrats
have become
business we know they want cheap labor
and activists believe a migrant influx
is key to changing America away from its
stubborn patriotism and all that old
traditionalism stuff
so talk to illegal immigrants today I
have and they'll tell you that they feel
like the bide Administration values
illegals over them and their
contributions
in a few moments we're going to tell you
how Biden's Fanatics are planning an
even greater assault on our sovereignty
now none of this leads to Greater
prosperity and the Democrats they know
it that's why they work with Facebook
and with Twitter to bury descent during
the 2020 election and why they're
desperate now to keep Tick-Tock going
despite its ties to China they don't
care about that
now why should Biden campaign at all in
2024 when he has big Tech doing it for
him and why answer questions at all
the press used to complain about
presidents who hide from their questions
but most hold their tongues here to
Shield Biden they know what happens when
he goes off the script
my name is Joe Biden
I'm Dr Joe Biden's husband
and I had Jenny's ice cream chocolate
chip
I came down because you heard there was
chocolate chip ice cream
by the way I have a whole refrigerator
full upstairs
well that's nice especially after a mass
shooting
now the Democrats abandoned first
principles for money power and the
adulation of the media and entertainment
complexes
this is why people like Glenn Greenwald
and Matt taibi have worked hard to
expose them and now you see them
occasionally on Fox to discuss issues in
depth that matter to people
that's why Tulsi gabbard left the party
and why so many Hispanic voters and now
Asian voters are moving toward the
Republicans
so progressives they're being played for
suckers they should have cut deals with
the populist Republicans
I think we could have built on the
success of the usmca that trade deal
that replaced NAFTA with other trade
deals
certainly not the trans-pacific
partnership
we could have worked to eliminate the
Patriot Act we could have reigned in the
war spending and pushed for new rules on
Industrial policy that would have really
encouraged jobs and Manufacturing in the
United States
but look the squad they hate us more
than they like their own working class
don't they
our model leads to more Prosperity
higher wages and more jobs their model
leads to less of everything
except maybe pot porn abortions and yeah
Wars
so all you need to know about the
Democrats versus the Republicans today
is this
and their transition they got Liz Cheney
and ours we got Tulsi gabbard
as Democrats continue to abandon the
people who make this country function
day in and day out conservative populist
candidates will scoop them up that's how
Republicans will win back the Senate and
win the presidency again
because now we're the party of Hope and
change and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else